But as far as the engineers, we are looking to remove them, move them to other work groups by the end of Friday.
Yeah.
So no pressure, but I think the team's doing well. I mean, have you seen any concerns with the first team, first group?
No.
No, I actually, I was just reviewing the since I was out yesterday, I get a I get a smile back report for CSATs every week. No negatives last week. I found there was a couple that showed some of the new folks already got some positive feedback. So
Yeah.
Mm.
Akshay.
Yeah.
So far, so good.
Sounds great. Sounds great. I gave John a brief update yesterday from what I got from Simeon.
But I'll let them know that we should be good to go on Friday.
Okay, that's great. Yeah, and we'll, here's what I'll say from our perspective, right? I mean, obviously, Pritam and I are here to support. So if you capture any risk that you feel will not work in our favor towards hitting that target on Friday, right?
Boston.
Yeah.
It's Tuesday now. I'm glad to hear that you're confident, but we want to help support where we can. So if anything does come up, please let us know. We can collaborate on an idea and an execution plan to like rectify if there's some new issue that crops up.
Got it, understood.
But yeah, so far, so good. I pretty much today, I've set it up so the ITBD engineers are pretty much in the driver's seat, so to speak, in terms of new things coming in. We still have a couple, US engineers are still around, but the ones that aren't shadowing, I pretty much.
put them on their more or less in the lowest prioritization for receiving things. So everything that comes in is going to go into the new folks first. And I specifically told them to work on, you know, just following up on any of their old stuff. I want to see if I can get them to close out as much as I can, because just like Chris said, I don't want them to have to take too many tickets with them to their new work groups.
Okay.
So, but no, I think I think we're doing good. I think we're on track and on target.
Awesome. Awesome. Thank you for sharing the detail. Yep. Pritam, I know I just circumvented your intention for the start of the meeting. I'll hand it back to you. Okay, brilliant.
Sounds great.
Mhm.
No, no, no, that's fine. That's fine. Actually, it's Rick, but Rick has to jump into a different call, William. So he sent his apologies that he won't be coming into this call. But yeah, quick things here. So we are going with that 7 to 7 coverage this Friday, William.
Okay.
Mm.
I was, you know what, that's a good point. I was going to ask, I was going to check with Rodge about that, but yeah, I think that'll work if we want to have everybody go to their new official shift times Friday. I think that works well.
Or do you want to start 27th? Or Friday is good.
I feel like I didn't want them to have to go into, I want to give them at least one opportunity to try working the new shift. I think Friday due to the lower volume, just to give them a chance to ease into a little more. So that way they can really hit the ground running on Monday, having, you know, already in the flow for how that's going to go. I think that would be easier for them.
Okay.
Yeah.
Perfect, perfect. And also I have Angel, Helen, and Carmina on for onboarding this 23rd. So they will continue with 8 to 5 Eastern shift, right, till they complete the trainings.
Mhm.
Correct.
Yeah.
So, you, sorry, Chris.
Sorry, yeah, so Lindsay just reached out to HR today to get their accounts created. I'll reach out to the internal team, make sure their accounts are ready by Thursday, so...
Okay.
OK, HR was still didn't have it all the information submitted for the new accounts to get created, so I'll make sure that that happens.
Mm.
Okay, sure. Thank you. Thank you, Chris. And they will be like working with William, like William is my POC for all three of them. Chris.
So, initially, well, they need to go through the new hire training, so...
Mhm.
Well, let me reach out to Emily, our trainer. Make sure that...
There, she's going to be taking them on on Thursday.
Okay.
Yeah, I know in our last meeting we talked about it. I gave her a heads up about the 23rd, but in fairness, I haven't followed up since. So yeah, we should probably reach out just one more time.
Kour.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Okay.
But the the accounts should everything should be submitted today to get the accounts ready by tomorrow, so.
Fair enough. Thank you. Thank you, Chris. And also, William, any update for me regarding the new HSS, right?
Acquisition.
Oh, I did, I got confirmation that that got corrected in our system. Let me find out, let me make sure, let me see where that stands in turn in the approval pipeline on our end, but I think they corrected the mistake I made in putting when I put in the rec the first time. I did get that confirmation from HR, so I just got to see where it stands now.
Thank you for reminding me about that.
Chopra.
Sure, let me know like once it gets approved so that I can align the interviews with you.
Yeah, okay.
Got it, will do.
That's all I have.
Ohh.
Yes, William, I sorry, Chris, you are saying something.
Go ahead, go ahead, go ahead.
So William, I was wondering, like, since we are starting this Friday with 7 to 7, I was actually doing a weekly touchpoint connect with the team at like 4.30 P.m. Eastern every week, every Wednesday in fact. So can I continue?
Mm.
Yeah.
PH.
that and take that time like it's like hardly 10 to 15 minutes connect.
Yeah, that's fine.
430 P.m. Eastern every Wednesday. That way I can connect with the entire team. Just the initial phase here. I know Rodge is doing his part of job. I just want to have some touch point and understand where they are facing any challenge, any help they need from my end or data price end and all the.
Yeah, that's okay.
And.
facilities from IT by design, like their commute, food, and et cetera, you know, because the entire team is new. So just want to extend my health there. I was doing this connect on a every week basis. So I'll just try like to continue it for next 60 to 90 days till the team settles. Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, that should be fine.
Well, I think I recommend you making sure that there's coverage, even though it's even if it's only 10 to 15 minutes.
Right.
Mm.
You know, there could be calls and tickets coming in, especially calls and chats coming in during that 10 to 15 minutes. So...
When that happens, yeah, I think definitely need to have a few of the maybe US police engineers at least covering. War or Pritam, are you able to like split that up into two sessions?
Yes.
Text online.
Yes, we can do that. We can do that. I can do it.
OK, that would be easier for William, so that he's we don't have to impact 'cause we're gonna we're gonna.
PH.
Yeah.
We may lose some of the U.S. space engineers, so we may not have enough people for coverage. OK, so I think having two sessions would be better for Will.
Absolutely.
Okay.
No, makes sense, Chris. Actually, this totally makes sense. I can do first half something in the morning and second half something in the afternoon. And I'll just check my calendar, William, and let you know what the timings. Just a weekly connection.
OK.
Earl.
Okay, would you mind sending me an invite to those as well? Just not, I don't need to be there for them, but just so I have it on my calendar as a reminder, like, so when I see like, oh, the team's going to be stepping away at this time, so.
Sorry.
Kour.
Right, I will add you.
Yeah.
Deepti.
Pritam, if you don't mind not having it in the morning, because mornings are very busy, right? If you could have it maybe Wednesday, half team, you know, Thursday, half in the afternoon, that would work much better. So.
Agreed, I'll use the evening.
Yu.
Definitely.
Yeah, 8 to 11 is the, it's like the rush hour for IV rehab.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Mhm.
Hello.
Definitely, Chris. Thank you.
As you know, coverage, yeah, that's the most important thing for Ivy, and you know, I just wanted to, you know, send out a reminder about that. Coverage is the most important thing, so...
And.
Um...
Do we, well, do we get many tickets like on holidays? ITBD is usually closed on US holidays.
Yeah, the only holiday that we ever had a problem with was the Friday of Thanksgiving. But that's actually not, yeah, that's not a problem now because it's not a holiday for ITBD. So they're all going to just be here already. So we don't actually have to try to find volunteers anymore. They'll already just be on shift.
Mm.
After Thanksgiving, OK.
That was the only one that from a Ivy perspective that there was a holiday. We do need to align on coverage for, I think there was a couple.
Okay.
Yeah.
couple of Philippines holidays that we're going to have to make sure we have coverage for. But for our purposes, the only day that was ever a problem was just that Friday of the week of Thanksgiving. But yeah, since that's not a holiday for them either, they're just going to be here anyway.
I.
Ashish.
I think that needs to be discussed in detail. Okay. And, but you know, they will have like Thanksgiving off, right? They'll take a US holiday like Thanksgiving Day. I know Christmas, it'll conflict. New Year's could conflict. New Year's, they're closed on New Year's, so that's.
That's it doesn't click, actually.
So it was same with Christmas, actually, 'cause when they're closed New Year's and Christmas, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah, so that's that's good.
Mhm.
Lee.
So don't worry, Chris, like I have other partners as well, like...
Yeah.
strategic partners who are running 24-7 even weekends here. So Philippines holiday, we get it covered, don't worry. So people, they opt to come to work. Christmas, New Year, Thanksgiving, IV, if they're closed, we are good to give them a holiday. If not,
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go.
Yeah.
We are good with skeletal stuffing. So the expectations are clear made. It's clearly made with the techs when we hire them. And they also understand that the business runs 24-7, 365.
Okay.
Understood, understood.
So maybe not all 10 people come on a Christmas on New Year, but maybe like 2 each shift, something like that.
Yeah, and Pritam, we we can we can get together because I I threw together like a quick little Excel sheet where I lined up all the holidays just so I could get a quick visualization of like, were there any days that would be a conflict? And we can run through that together just to call out the days that'll that'll be because I have a column basically for Philippine holidays, call it a column for.
And.
Ohh.
Data Prize holidays, and then a column for Ivy's holidays specifically, just to call out the specific ones. And I feel like the only one that was a concern, well, there were no concerns on the, you know, as far as like our holidays are concerned, but it definitely did highlight the few days off top of my head. Oh, I see you just posted something in chat. Let's see.
I.
I think this is the one you are talking about.
Yes, yes, okay. Yeah, because I gave it to me. Oh, I did. Oh, all right, there we go.
You, you send that to me, yeah.
You send it to me. So like 16th Feb, 1st of May, like US and Ivy both for holiday. The team gets a holiday here. 25th May, I think entire your team, Data Price team and Ivy is off. And ITBD Philippines is also off. So they get the holiday on 25th of May.
Yes.
We need coverage on 12th of June, because it's a holiday in IT by design, but IV and Taylor Price is working. Now, another one is 27th of November, I think. We need coverage for IV.
Mhm.
Yeah, that's the Friday I was talking about. So that's, it's a data prize holiday, but it's not an Ivy holiday. And so from the list of holidays that Rodge gave me, it didn't look like it was a holiday for you all either. So I feel like we're good there. But yeah, definitely. And this year, because obviously you guys just came on, so a lot of the, for some of the holidays, at least I think the one at the beginning of April, you know, they were just in training. So it was,
Yeah.
Right.
Yes.
easy enough to just let them take that day off. But I actually forgot about the one on May 1st. We definitely do need them here on May 1st.
Mhm.
Right.
Yeah, they're coming.
Okay.
Mae first, I think.
Yeah, I was gonna...
Sorry, Lee, just a complete method. May 1st was our initial go live date, if you remember.
And should, and should.
Yes, yes, okay. All right, just making sure, as I was looking at this chart again, I was just like, oh, crap, I forgot about the May 1st one. And that was the reason why I wanted to bring it up, because that definitely is like the go-live date, so I wanted to make sure we were covered there. But okay, all good. But yeah, for, I guess, at this point, the only, yeah, to your point.
Haha.
Yeah.
I think June 12th is the only one that we were next, or that's the next one we would need to align coverage for, and that takes care of the year. Then we just got it prepared for 2027.
At.
Punch and Saladaga.
Yeah, and our objective is to make that easy for you. So that's part of why we provide the information right up front. Obviously, you know, we work just like any other service team. Sometimes people got to work. Sometimes they have to work a holiday and it might happen, right? So, you know, our objective here isn't to like...
Yeah.
lock you guys into giving a full team or a full shift, everybody off and fill it back, fill it elsewhere. Our objective is to figure out, okay, what is reasonable? What can we, what can be accomplished? We want to accommodate as many people as we can, but we got to keep a business running on all sides.
Yep.
Sounds good.
Okay, I do have one other news.
I actually submitted my resignation at the beginning of the month.
So, my last day will be May, sorry, April 30th.
Yes.
I will continue to help assist you guys until then. William, I recommend having Jose Correa join these meetings going forward.
Okay.
Okay, because he needs to be aware of what's going on.
Oh.
Because I think it will help you in the long run, so...
Yeah, understood.
Yeah, and I'll also notify him as well, so...
But I appreciate all the help, Pritam. I think you guys did a great job of.
Helping us.
Bring in the new team, and...
Just glad to see that they're doing very well, so I've heard the other.
So far so good with the feedback on their performance, so that's great.
Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you, Chris.
Yep.
Yeah, thank you for sharing, Chris. First off, congratulations. I hope that this is, you submitted your resignation, so I hope that's for greener pastures or at least the next step for you. So that's great to hear. Is there any,
Mam.
Yeah.
Exactly, I...
Yeah, yeah.
Do you know who William?
Shh.
And us will be working directly with a long-term solution or just a short-term.
So.
Well, so, yeah, so that's why I recommend to bring in Jose Correa. It doesn't look like they're going to replace my role at this time.
Okay.
So, I mean, you know, ultimately, John Coffin is the decision maker. So, William and Jose needs to reach out to John to just make any final decisions. But as far as, you know, the day-to-day operations, of course, William is in charge.
Ohh.
Yep.
OK.
Jose Korea will just support him.
Yep.
PH.
when needed, you know, when William is out or if he, you know, if he needs to reach out to John and to ask certain questions or something like that. So, but you're in good hands with William. He's made the ITBD team very successful and...
Yeah.
Mm.
So, he is the man, he is the man, yeah.
Yeah, no, no, no doubt, no doubt.
Appreciate it.
Yeah. Him and Simeon, they tag team to make idea a success. So I'm sure you guys will keep that success going. So.
S.
But yeah, Jose, Korea should join. I'll ask him to join the next meeting on the 28th.
which would be my final meeting with you guys, but I'll definitely keep IT by Design in mind. I was very impressed with the team, you know, and hey, you never know if we run to each other again, so.
Well, that would be lovely. And Chris, I don't know if you look on LinkedIn, everyone just sent you a connection request. So if you're.
I.
Sounds great. I'll definitely accept. Yeah, thanks. Thanks for that. And sorry for not turning the camera. My eyes are really swollen right now due to allergies and that's why I have the cameras on, so.
Earl.
Yeah.
Hi.
I would put on the emotions, but...
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, that's great. Thank you for sharing.
Yeah.
Alright, anything else, Team?
Mm.
From our side.
No, man.
I'm good, I'm good, yeah. For the onboardings, we shared the data, so everything is good.
Okay.
Beautiful.
Sounds great.
Thank you so much, De.
All right.
Thank you all, Chris.
Thank you, Chris. Yeah, thank you.
Huh?
Alright, have a great day. Bye.
Take care, everybody.
Cheers!
Bye.